It's now being reported that Donald Trump
person, we use the sharpie to draw a bubble
on hurricane Dorian's track map, which was
inaccurate.
We don't want to give more importance to sharpie
gate than it deserves, especially when when
you look at what Donald Trump is doing at
the border or geo-politically with Iran, with
climate, with our allies, that is all so much
worse than so much more impactful than sharpie
gate.
But sharpie gate is worth talking about in
that it reflects a delusional and unsettling
commitment to an absolutely backwards of the
truth.
That signals a fundamentally unwell person
in Donald Trump, which won't come as a surprise
to people who have been watching me for a
while.
So to catch you up if you haven't followed
this story and I envy you if that's the case.
Donald Trump tweeted last week that hurricane
Dorian was putting Alabama at risk.
It wasn't.
Instead of just saying, oh, it wasn't [inaudible],
Donald Trump doubled, tripled and quadrupled
down climaxing in holding up a version of
the hurricane track map that had an additional
bubble drawn around parts of Alabama.
Now this was not an official weather map and
we knew it was doctored partially because
as more as you go into the future the whole
way, let me see if I can explain this.
The way that these cones of possible hurricane
trajectory work is that they become wider
and more encompassing over time because uncertainty
goes up the further into the future you're
predicting.
So the fact that a smaller cone of the possible
track was, was drawn in later in the hurricane
is mathematically impossible, but putting,
if you didn't realize that this was not an
official weather map, we knew it was doctored,
but the White House now is saying that Donald
Trump personally drew the sharpie bubble.
This is according to the Washington Post and
official from the White House saying that
quote, no one else writes like that on a map
with a black sharpie.
Now, I will tell you, this is so obvious to
me.
The only thing that makes me doubted is that
when I imagine Donald Trump drawing, I don't
envision him having a steady enough hand to
draw such a clean circle between his sort
of erratic demeanor in speeches is sniffing
and huffing and puffing his signature that
looks like an EKG.
I would imagine if you told Donald Trump to
draw a circle that it would be a shaky circle,
but other than that, of course we suspected
that Donald Trump did this himself.
This makes his confused denial the other day,
even funnier though.
Remember this, when Donald Trump was asked
about a sharpie being used and he just looked
away and repeated that he doesn't know
and that map to utilize, they looked like
these homes that in a sharpie.
I don't know.
I don't know that map today.
It looks like it's almost like like a sharpie.
I don't know.
That map that you, us today, it looked like,
was that like a sharpie?
I don't know.
It was him.
Of course, it was him the whole time and another
minor flub, uh, again that no one would have
cared about had Donald Trump not tripled down
and quadrupled down on it.
It's sort of like the supposedly record setting,
inauguration crowd all over again, or three
to 5 million people voted illegally for Hillary
Clinton and otherwise I would have won the
popular vote.
You say it once as outrageous as it is, but
then you just let it go or admit that you
were wrong.
Or at least you don't fight it tooth and nail
and it mostly goes away.
Instead when you go after and double and triple
and quadruple down, it becomes huge and hugely
embarrassing to anyone who even has the capability
to have a sense of shame.
It's not clear, Donald Trump does.
And this is just insecurity, right?
When you were so insecure that you can't even
admit to the most minor mistake, uh, you really
show what is actually going on there.
And this is not, you know, mind reading or
speculation.
It's the most benign possible explanation
of Donald Trump choosing to double, triple,
and quadruple down on obvious lies.
Insecurity is the least bad explanation.
The others are far, far worse.
So maybe this is the end of sharpie gate.
I don't know.
Uh, but we will see if this rears its ugly
head.